research suggests too much sleep it's
bad for your health a study published
published in the Journal of the American
Heart Association found that people
sleep 10 hours a night who are those
people
surely than those who slept for eight
hours the risk for death from stroke and
cardiovascular disease also increased
paper looked at 74 studies involving 3.3
million people so that seems like a big
study our doctor Tara nurullah is a
cardiologist at New York's Lenox Hill
Hospital that's part of the northwell
health organization I never think of you
dr. Tara's a liar liar pants on fire I
can't wrap my brain I'm getting too much
sleep is bad for you yes in the words of
Shakespeare there may be too much of a
good thing in this in this study it's
really unclear what the mechanism is
yeah but how could it be so the question
is is it the sleep itself that's
creating the increased risk or is it
that people who sleep longer have
underlying problems medical conditions
that are making them at risk and they're
sleeping longer because of their
underlying conditions so what types of
underlying conditions if they have
anaemia some sort of chronic
inflammatory disorder depression if they
have sleep apnea those are gonna
increase their risk it's also gonna
potentially make them sleep longer could
it be that the biology changes with
changes in their circadian rhythm by
sleeping longer and that's causing
increased inflammation weakening of
their immune system could it be that
they have other adverse health behaviors
so people who sleep longer maybe they
don't exercise as much and last but not
least could it be completely unrelated
and have to do more with unemployment or
socioeconomic status and and that may be
factoring in so a lot of questions still
that we need to answer but certainly
this was a very big study and this is
what they found increased risk what does
it mean for people who try to catch up
on sleep on the weekends and especially
with people who my name is Gail yeah
people who don't have kids who try to
catch up right so in the research would
suggest that this is meant for people
who are really sleeping nine or ten
hours consistently every single day for
long periods of time not just people who
sleep low amounts during the week and
then try to catch up on the weekend but
really what you need to remember is
consistent and regular sleep health
patterns are important so a sleep
hygiene regimen where you're going to
bed and waking up
at the same time where you have a cool
quiet darkroom putting your devices away
you're not drinking caffeine or alcohol
right before bed and you're exercising
on a daily basis all of this helps so
why should doctors then ask their
patients about their sleep patterns how
important is that for doctors Amit it's
really important in fact the American
Heart Association put out a statement in
2016 saying that your regular sleep
increases risk and we need to ask about
both duration of sleep and quality of
sleep and if we find that there's some
irregularity we need to screen people
for increased cardiovascular risk for
risk factors and potentially something
for sleep studies if we think they have
sleep apnea
yeah years ago doctors never asked now
doctors are asked you're learning about
more of these quote non-traditional risk
factors and how important they are
things like stress and your pregnancy
history in terms of raising your
cardiovascular risk so just to remember
ages 18 to 64 regular sleep seven to
nine hours is recommended grade over
nine dividing up 75 Harris try thank you
thank you sleeping on the weekend over
54 what happens to those jamokes
over 54
6400 I thought you said over 65 17 hours
okay
yes we are good